something that just blew up the streamer
Wednesday fans snapped up a
record-breaking
341 plus million hours up yeah The Adams
Family inspired series breaking the
record set by stranger things 4 and our
Denny directo is with the man who had a
hand in that the actor playing thing
mother and father sent you to spy on me
didn't they be my thing I'm dressed as
Gomez okay I got a Mia
thinking it was all CGI instead magician
Victor dorobonsu wore a full body blue
suit hit under tables crouched behind
Jenna Ortega and even shot scenes
underwater to make thing come to life
I knew it
hello thing I'm curious what the
audition process like for thing it's a
really hard process because you have to
uh to show emotions to a simple hand
that doesn't have voice or subtitles
what is it that you want hand cream nail
buffer new cuticle scissors
consider it done
I will say the thing in this show looks
a little battered and beaten up a little
bit oh he's building up but he's like
next level superhero he has so much
character I'll sing poor naive appendage
did you have to do like hand exercises
as you were preparing for the role a lot
of them show me let's see uh what what
kind of uh gesture should I show you a
good one let's try it together let's
let's this is your Podium okay walk on
it walk on my hand okay and show some
love like let's do it oh yeah
[Music]